these days practically all carmakers
have a presence in the booming SUV
segment off-roaders big in small and in
all manner of variations are now popping
up like mushrooms
among the older hands here is the BMW x3
it's been on the market for 12 years now
for more than one of its biggest rivals
the VW tiguan
the latest second-generation was given a
facelift in 2014 the design is classic
but not exactly Darren other
manufacturers take a far more courageous
approach when it comes to designing
their SUVs we checked out the xDrive 20
iverson of the x3 with an 8-speed
automatic transmission coupled with
all-wheel drive packing 135 kilowatts of
power the car needs eight point two
seconds to accelerate from 0 to 100 km/h
217 newton meters of torque make this a
sturdy mover thus far 526 our car man
Chris likens the x3 strive ability to
that of a sedan it's agile sporting and
dynamic but even if most owners won't
need it offroad the xdrive all-wheel
drive performs extremely well it's a
safe and solid drive the x3 measures
four meters 66 from tail to nose making
it 24 centimeters longer than the VW
tiguan and one of the biggest models in
its class and you really notice that
from the interior space both for
rear-seat passengers and cargo Mitzvah
fuel the cargo capacity of around 400
liters is a little lower than its
predecessor but you still have an
enormous amount of room to stow away
your personal effects is on a spective
Chris finds the rear particularly
handley for transporting bulkier items
such as skis
the instruments and display units have a
slick sobriety about them you can
operate a variety of functions with the
idrive controller which includes a touch
pad for typed in text entry comparing
the entry-level models of the tiguan and
x3 the BMW is around 12 and a half grand
crazier that's it overall the x3 is in
the higher cost bracket but for that you
get good quality and great workmanship
plus acres of space on the rear bench to
one minor downside all-round visibility
could be better